but hopefully I will convince you by the
end of the talk that there is a lower
bound
please interrupt me anyway if there's
something else
okay so one of the ultimate goals in
proof complexity is to show that you
know following a lower bounds for any
propositional proof system
and we know about by quick record tell
them that this is equivalent to the
statement which says that NP
is not equal to currency
you know several strong lower bounds for
different proofs big proof systems such
as resolution cutting planes
constantly and so on
but if we go a little bit higher we
don't know like any lower mount for for
example even resolution that works
with realities or like constantive
figure that can use parity Gates
so
why cannot you know why we cannot
improve the situation so apparently
there are two problems
the first problem is that we don't know
how to draw ones like there is a lack of
methods you don't know like there is no
a like a universal framework that we can
think indeed and improve our balance and
the other thing which is also very
important is that like to prove lower
bounds we need a formula
formula and then you start to try prove
dollar one you don't have any good
candidates
so what are the like candidates that we
have like there are three main
candidates
the first one is random formulas for
example like random dnfs it's some good
densities
second one is the final consistency from
us so kind of consistency
formula says that you have some
propositional proof system key con P of
n says that there is no P proof of
quantitation of Links at most n
and the reason that we believe that like
this consistency
formulas should be
hard is that it's because of this
theorem by Karachi and putlock
so there is no optimal for positional
proof system if and only for any
proposition for system P there is
another propositional processing queue
such that the finite consistency
formulas of Q does not have policized
pifos
believe that you know this is true so we
get a
company of our pathologies for any proof
system but
but I mean there are some problems with
this because like this is
non-constructive so like if I put
extended here we don't know what Q
should be like whether it's gone on
arithmetic zfc like something very
strong
depend on what Q is you have to
process
yeah there is a cycle here
so and the third example which is uh the
main topic of this talk is proof complex
generators
so what is a proof complexity generator
suppose you have some function G that
Maps NB test links to MB test strings
and M is bigger than n
and it has low complexity let's say G
can be computed in people
and so as it has low complexity we can
for any output this I we can write a
propositional formula like this in which
if you plug some a in P like this
formula is satisfiable if and only if G
of a equals to J
and now uh
you can write a propositional formula
Tau VG for some
be here says that b is not in the range
of G
so it's good
and we call such a g heart proof
complexity generator for some proof
system if for any string outside of each
range like this formula requires
long proof
so every third string well I mean the
original conjecture was the original
definition is for everything but you can
say like say that for almost everything
it is
doing known about the
wrong condition of every or just one bit
any example that we have is like any
lower bond that we know is for every
for example if you consider two strip
table generator you cannot consider it
like for every Forest various soundproof
system assuming like uh
is not in people for example
so so what are candidates functions
okay so at the audience of uh proof
complexity general interest is like
there are two like Origins so one was by
Electronics
so they started with this like the fact
that prgs are important in computational
complexity
so they asked the following National
question which mapping should be
considered thoughts of food companies
um
a computational complexity we can see
them as tickets like proof complexity or
like non-deterministic that's so that's
the question
um
the second origin was a you know work by
Christchurch so he considered like
several uh
versions of pigeonhole principle in
bounded Pro systems especially this dual
implemented more principle which we have
seen previously says that uh
there is something which is not in the
range
and the question that was uh he was
interested was whether S12 and S12 plus
is 12 equation mode principle
it's the same or not
so we know that like if we put PV here
under like some assumptions these two
are different parts for S12 this is
completely open
yes there's a third paper
um like Stephen rudish that's basically
yes in the same question in more
confusing language yeah
which
benefits
whatever which question is repeated
the question of whether
like their random constructions but it
is asking about a randomly
that's true and that's important
distinction because for example if you
consider random CNS corresponder proof
complexity generators which is too
consideration for randomly
and okay and he showed that like if
there is a hard proof complexity
generator for extended
section
okay so so here I'm going to explain an
example of what candidate proof
complexity hard candidate hard proof
complete generator so and it's missing
videos and Generator
so this is the definition of Nissan
videos and Generator we have some uh
base Boolean function
yes and we have some Matrix a which is M
times n zero one LS bars which means
that each row has exactly l1s and N
minus l0
and Nissan videos on based on F and a
Define the function from n Bits to n
Bits like this so the output of the
output
is uh you take a you restrict it to the
places that's in that row there are ones
you concatenate those bits and you apply
it
and that's the function so
and let's uh and
let me show that but if
f is an anti-inter sequently then how we
wear some Nissan videos from FNA can be
written as a proposition formula so we
can talk about it again uh two system
and the main conjecture about
this Nissan dealership generators is by
razorov so he conjectured that anyway
some Nissan Victorian generator based on
suitable matrices and any heart function
in any fantastic quality any hard on
average uh
function for people is hard for extended
failure
well I mean for to to have a good Nissan
videos engineer you have to put like the
combinatorial properties on The Matrix
but like this is the general definition
okay so why this conjecture is
interesting
so the first reason is that it implies
hardness of computation employs harness
of proof so we have such a relation for
weak proof system which is of physical
interpolation property but uh
when we go to First and extend forget it
fades
uh and what we know about the status of
this conjecture is that like young chick
proved that if P has feasible
interpolation property then last words
and texture holds 40 so
for example this time that supports for
resolution or cutting planes if we
measure
size bit of fighting planes
and the strongest evidence that we have
to support the conjecture is uh you
should say what it means
the same extension but here we provide
another process
all right
and uh estargus evidence we have is done
by kratchex so he showed that like for
any like essentially the Assumption of
the conjecture
he showed that like pv1 cannot prove use
some leadership is not onto
extending this P1 to S12 and slice the
original appendix
so why
Nissan Victor's engineers
and large so because of the following
four reasons so one is the complexity of
it another one is like the combinatorial
properties that Matrix a satisfy so for
something it might be easier to prove
normal or not and if you extend the
result in the previous slide for S12
then you get an extended fragile yeah
this is the way that he did like
crashes if you somehow can extend
project construction you get an extended
almost I mean because you get the
conjunction right
through the condition
you get a conditional lower one for
example if that's what you mean
what condition
s
if there is a power function and
interception for people
when it improve the conjecture and you
assume that you know the assumption is
true then you get the lower one for
instance
assume that the function is hard on
average or
connection
but if it's entering the quantity is
already independent so you cannot say
another
excuse me are you saying that if S12
doesn't prove that the significance
yeah then you get the lower bound on
extended credit well almost that's what
you get the conditional over
here you have to start with the model
which is another to write nothing and
they should the model should be
expansion of that
satisfied this one
yeah like this is like a vegetable
chicken
horizontal
like in S12 you have a Sharpie bounded
yeah which means that you can confident
this falsifying assignment for the topic
formula
so you get like one string which
falsifies everything
foreign so here I said that we have to
like represent if
because there are several
representations
so if f is in NP intersect quantity like
for any end we can write the two
propositional formula one is for the
entry part one is for the quantity part
which satisfies the natural properties
and defines it
and if we have like these Sigma 0 and
sigma 1 we can write the Tau be formula
here
the important thing here is that these
two eyes are different
now I have to specify
what Sigma zero and sigma one I want to
work
so I want to give some example
so I can say that the parity of some
string x equals to zero can be defined
by the following first order formula so
here x is a unit relation Y is a binary
relation
and this formula is true which is this
if you can if y defines the pairing over
the ones of x
this is what this formula says
and uh
so this is an example of like first
order formula so if it's a existential
coupon if I over y it becomes a sigma 1
1 formula and it's not important is but
this is just an example too
what's going on
and we can translate these formulas to
propositional formulas it is a single
one formulas to proposition formula so
this is the translation of the
this formula will be just uh for every
like if it's x i we put Pi if it's y i j
we put like q i j and then Universal
quantifiers becomes conjunctions and
existential points becomes disjunctions
and that's our formula
so here is the
definition of what signal formula is so
again you have like some first order
formula like the example that you had
for the parity
there are some binary alternative or
whatever relations here
and this formula defines your functions
like the way that we had this mortality
um so one important thing is that like
this Sigma 1 formulas are assigned so
you can express any symmetric entry
property
and uh another important property of
these things is that uh
they are closed under permutations which
means that like so here in the parity
formula if you start with this
this is assumed and this is your pairing
if I
uh
if I swap these two bits
and
swap the pairing and you get like again
this stain but there's the formula still
is true for this
this is why it goes under permutations
so now like this Sigma on 1.1 where
software quality so we can Define again
representation based on them so the
representation becomes like the Paris
multi translation of them
um this is the statement of the Torah
for constantive trigger
so
again we have a function in entry
sequently but here our function is
symmetric
that requires exponential size depth to
ac0 circuits
then if we choose like 5051 Sigma 1 Pi
one representation of F and a is a good
Matrix and B outside of the lanes then
the Tau B formula based on this
representation
requires line is your figure proofs
so this is your tip yeah okay
it's known about symmetric function
hardness
because
a lot of applications
sorry we know even more characterization
of which symmetric functions at least
but here it needs to be
oh and jc0 right sorry
the reason you use this signal one
encoding versus like just using the
circuits Computing it is
so that one is completely it's very hard
question
um
[Music]
so obviously there was something
automated I mean it's hard to say it's
hard to explain it right now but I will
say something about it later
okay so if the search is exponential you
get polynomial in the size of the
formula if it's for the search is
polynomial exponential
okay
what do you mean by long if you have it
in Red so yeah looking at the total size
you're looking at the number of lines I
don't know um like if a if the stretch
is exponential then you get a lower
amount of polynomial size
exponential size
I mean I didn't want to write
but it's
so but still it depends so if we say
stretch to be like quadratic or
something then it's going to be really
exciting
okay
now how much time
it's all free yes I do
okay so here this is the statement of uh
logic so it says that if you have like
some proposition formula Phi Phi has an
extended trigger proof if and only if
it's true under every assignment
so this means that if you want to show a
lower bound to show that something does
not have a proof you just need to find a
falsifying assignment right
but this thing cannot be used to prove
lower amounts for excellent strategies
like this kind of a statement because
the formula that we start with is
already a tautology
so there is a soundness and confidence
for short proof
hopefully so here I am in an arbiting on
a standard model of trade which means
that
um
numbers which is like bigger than
everything that we know but like they
are satisfies every properties that you
know like there are infinitely primes
here like you can talk about graphs and
so on
and so here this says that we want to
like cut this m something like this
and everything which has links
polynomial in N to Decay like if you
look at the bit representation
and the soundness and completeness
problem says that so here instead of one
formula we have we should have a family
of formulas it says that this formula
formula has a policies extended proofs
if and only if for however you extended
this model to a model of pv1
and in that model Phi and is a tautology
so does this have anything to do with it
the rate of growth that you can prove
it
but if you have a voice
explanation then but you can prove you
can prove any psychology in an
exponential side so
here we
wanted to learn for ac03 I guess so
use this story
which I'm going to explain in a moment
so this is
zero so it has like X basic action about
additional multiplication of essentially
Q as the previous talk and we have
induction for any bounded formula
that
it should be bigger than one and for any
Y and Z less time
is X then one of them is should be
and uh but relativized item.0 is
essentially the same as I double zero
but here your induction formulas can
have
four
now
this is the only lower one that I want
to show that to how we can programs in
this framework
so the thickness is that the other
one by one uh definition of editing
foreign
so we know by the fact that pigeon mode
principle requires long spool like One
Direction of the Summers
we can find some function f
so I can reach this is the structure
with some function f such that uh
like it is a one-to-one onto from n plus
one to n but we still have it for 0r
and now consider like these two strings
like in Allah
and you have like one uh answer this
question one n plus one zero n and Theta
is one to the N 0 n plus one
so Phi 1 is true when the number of ones
is uh odd so we can but we know that
also has a number of points so we can
find something here which satisfy this
again the same thing for beta and Phi
zero
but uh as I said like these formulas are
closed under permutations
so I consider this G
this G so it match the end date or F
minus one it is
the second part so if you have what this
is all one this is zero it's like if you
you somehow
Matthew is one to this one in a way that
the first part includes the maps to the
first one and the second one after the
second
so and if you apply G to the weakness
to here you get that you know five zero
Alpha G of support
so this is to
this is true and so the conduction is
which is a falsifying assignment
so the first two uh first bullet so one
for mm is a cut yeah
is an explanation
so this is okay this is not about the
generator office
questions
funds was going to be true for the like
how we formed so
we have a lot of these equations
and once you like falsify them
simultaneously
but we have to choose one X which is
going to be like cut it to everyone so
the way that we use x is to
we randomly choose one and zero and we
apply channel one in a way that's like
the place that
for example for piety we here we had
like
an N plus one so like this is the place
that we want to have these many ones and
this many zeros so we choose the
probability in such a way that when the
when we get the lower bound like these
things are not too far from The Middle
and uh again we use
pigeonhole principle
but now so in the authority example we
just needed to like shrink by one bits
but here because like we have it's not
the distance might be more than one bit
we might we need to shrink by more than
one bit or stage by more than one bit so
if you have like something that fails
pigeonhole principle you can shrink by
more than like I mean here this is a
function that we can do so it Maps kl to
KL minus K so for each part L you map it
to L minus one so there is a
difference
this gives you the lower bound
this this was very like intuitive so
there are three applications of it the
first one is that you can get the lower
one for random formulas you choose a
random string outside of which is a
randomized thing and if you choose the
Matrix randomly so with high probability
it's a
uh unsatisfiable formula and from the
previous theorem you get the lower one
second application is that uh
you can say some formalization of this a
statement does not have a polynomial
size breaker proof
and the reason is that so we have like
very efficient uh way of constructing
the
good matrices
design matrices and like if you fix your
f
then you get some kind of a special
circuits and these like the input to the
animation videos and becomes your advice
so you have like those uh
those kind of Secrets I mean your
function does not have those kinds of
Secrets
or the open problems
the first one is to use the like circuit
definition of the policy
the second one is so here the only
function that I considered was symmetric
functions but suppose you have a binary
relation you can talk about like graph
properties so can you prove the same
problem for that and the third question
is suppose you enrich your proof system
by count modular free axioms so can you
prove the same tolerant when function f
is symmetric and hard for ac0
.
oh yeah so yeah
isn't it possible that the mpsi foreign
so I think it's going to also follow for
higher debt
is there a reason that you didn't put
it then it might be some time
is hard for
um
I mean the argument that I mentioned
does not work in this in this case why
it's not black box like if you have to
but I can hear the lower one that we
have is by demons
there is a PhD lower Bound for this
system where Dean and Lease
sorry if you assume that you had a lower
down
what if you assumed you had a lower
Bound for some version
like it's one bit I mean I have hardness
for n plus 1 to n if you have like
hardness for n plus one to like P to
Decay to end then teams get better
business at least I couldn't do that
so it's the option if you have
internet season order for the end yeah
so I guess so it has to take a further
questions of flights
on again